tous les trois ans le canada fixe un
nombre de personnes qui peuvent entrer
sur le territoire chaque année ses
objectifs cibles peuvent ensuite être
ajustés tous les ans pour 2019
l'objectif a été fixé à 330 mille
personnes soit un peu moins de 1% de la
population du pays
ce système là nous concerne que
l'immigration permanente ne concerne pas
les étudiants ne concerne pas les
travailleurs temporaires
donc on est sûr uniquement l'immigration
permanente des personnes qui ont
vocation à s'installer sur le canada le
canada privilégie des candidats à
l'immigration qui peuvent servir le
développement de son économie avec et
des critères de sélection très précis
ils ont différents programmes alors mais
les provinces ont beaucoup de pouvoir
notamment
le québec qui va privilégier des adéens
des personnes francophones 1 au point
des raisons vous imaginez ça va être à
la fois sur des questions de compétence
mais s'ils n'ont pas forcément
privilégié les personnalités au niveau
de compétence ils peuvent avoir besoin
de personne aide à la personne notamment
et un programme spécifique pour pour
cette catégorie là et finalement leur
leurs capacités ou leur art leur
aptitude à pouvoir s'insérer dans la
société à canadienne le regroupement
familial représente un quart du nombre
d'immigrés au canada mais ils sont
généralement comptabilisés avec
l'immigration économique au canada
quant à un étranger arrive pour des
raisons professionnelles qui fait venir
sa famille sa famille va rentrer dans la
catégorie immigration économique entre
pas dans la catégorie mingas familiale
donc là aussi il ya souvent un
malentendu en france quand on considère
que 60% l'immigration au canada est une
immigration économique alors que nous
elle est beaucoup plus faible parce qu
on est autour de 10 15%
donc la part de personnes qui rejoignent
soit des étrangers soit des canadiens et
finalement certainement aussi importante
qu'on france le modèle canadien a déjà
inspiré l'australie et la nouvelle
zélande et peut être bientôt la france